ça c'est un semi d'oignons du coup je
les prix parce que bientôt je vends ma
mère et elle a un petit potager donc je
vais lui donner la semaine de
l'environnement a débuté à l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
après une première journée consacrée aux
mobilités douces rendez vous ce mardi
autour du thème de la fourche à la
fourchette organisatrice de l'événement
l'association étudiante icare occupe son
propre stand on a une distribution de
semis on a des dégustations de jus de
pommes de producteurs locaux on a de la
confiture de lait c'est important parce
que déjà on montre toujours que on est
ici et que ya quand même une vie
associative à la fac et que
que voit là aussi il existe d'autres
associations dans le hall du bâtiment
d'alembert à guyancourt d'autres
associations locales sont venus
sensibiliser les jeunes à leur manière
on a préparé un quizz pour pouvoir
introduire de manière ludique les
activités de terry cité puissance qui
mise et plus généralement sur sur voilà
le travail de l'association on va
discuter un peu de tous ces projets de
comment on peut participer à
l'organisation d'aider ce qu'on aime
dire aussi que c'est un outil pour que
les personnes qui habitent ce territoire
peut s'en saisir pour mener à bien leurs
projets sociaux et écologiques objectif
de la semaine enseigner aux étudiants
qu'il est possible d'agir localement en
faveur de l'écologie déjà aujourd'hui on
voit qu'il ya des personnes là on vient
juste d'installer ville associatif et il
ya déjà des personnes qui nous posent
des questions donc ça veut dire que
quand on est plutôt
confiant et confiante pour les arts et
la semaine mercredi une journée sera
consacrée à la question du salariat
étudiant jeudi des ateliers autour de
l'éducation populaire et en prime des
conférences tous les soirs de la semaine